وانا بحبك والله انا بحبكم
تقدير مشواري الفن الطويل اللي بدا وانا
عندي خمس سنين متواصل لحد اللحظه اللي انا
عايشه فيها دي وبعدين
مهمه قوي لانه مهرجان القاهره مهرجان
الاستاذ الفنان الكبير رئيس مهرجان
القاهره الاستاذ حسين الثاني
[موسيقى]
ربنا زي ما يعوز هو مكتوب لي اتكرم يوم
عيد ميلادي يعني حاجه غريبه فعلا
المعادل المهرجان كان متحدد من زمان
اتولد انا تولدت يوم 13 الساعه 12:00 كان
ايدوني 14 نوف
[موسيقى]
لاني بافتكر والدتي هي كانت وراء مشوار
الفن الطويل هي اللي جابتني الدنيا وهي
اللي تعبت معي وهي اللي كانت بتختار
الافلام
وهي كانت من جواها بتحب الفن جدا
وهي علمتني حاجات كثير الاخلاص للفن
والتفاني
وان
دائما ابقى واخده بالي من جمهوري واحافظ
على جمهوري
وباعتبره يعني جمهوري هو والفن هو النفس
اللي بيتنفسه
[موسيقى]
ربنا يقف جنب مصر ويبعد عنها كل حاجه وحشه
نفسي دلوقتي في مخرج
جديد يكون زي الله يرحمه عاطف الطيب
ويكتشف في موهبه جديده الناس ما شافتهاش
[موسيقى]
بحب السي ان ان العربي و دائما متابعها
باي